The "Spider-Verse" is bigger than ever before in
the Oscar-winning movie's first sequel. If you
thought "Into the Spider-Verse" was dense with
Easter eggs, hold on to your web-shooters – you
ain't seen nothing yet. Warning: spoilers
ahead for Spider-Man: Across the Spider-Verse.
Though "Into the Spider-Verse"
functions as a cohesive narrative,
"Across the Spider-Verse" is the first
part of a completed story, with "Beyond
the Spider-Verse" set to pick up where it
leaves off. However, "Across the Spider-Verse"
continues to use a lot of the film language
the original established. One of those motifs
is the use of comic book covers to establish new
characters, as well as catch up with older ones.
"Alright people, let's do this one last time."
The film opens with narration from Gwen Stacy of
Earth-65, examining her backstory as Spider-Woman
and teasing her betrayal of Miles later on. Many
of those who watched "Into the Spider-Verse" will
recognize the similarities between this opening
sequence and the introduction of Chris Pine's
Peter Parker in the first film. Some fans may
notice that Stacy's comic book cover drops on
top of the existing covers that were shown
in "Into the Spider-Verse." The trend also
continues for the re-introduction of Miles,
as well as the introduction of new characters.
Furthermore, some of these comic book covers
allude to the characters' narrative history.
For Miles' first proper meeting with Miguel
O'Hara, otherwise known as Spider-Man 2099, the
comic book cover that flashes on screen directly
references the first issue of "Spider-Man 2099."
Miles Morales remains the protagonist of "Across
the Spider-Verse," but the extended opening of
the film centers the narrative on Gwen Stacy
following the events of "Into the Spider-Verse."
When she's not slinging webs and avoiding
captivity, Gwen also shreds on the drum kit, which
serves as the opening image of the film. After
she's finally interrupted mid-solo, comic book
fans will notice her bass drum, which is labeled
"The Mary Janes." Obviously, this fictional band
name is a direct reference to Mary Jane Watson,
who is Peter Parker's other notable love interest.
However, Gwen's involvement in The Mary
Janes dates back to her comic book origins.
The band made their debut in Spider-Gwen's
introductory comic, "Edge of Spider-Verse,"
released in 2014. In that comic, her fellow
band members are established as Betty Brant,
a version of Mary Jane Watson who later
becomes Carnage, and Gloria Grant.
Over the years, many actors have taken on
characters in the "Spider-Man" franchise,
but arguably only one performer has redefined an
iconic antagonist of Peter Parker's. That actor is
none other than J.K. Simmons, who will forever be
remembered as J. Jonah Jameson of The Daily Bugle.
"Crap. Crap. Mega crap. I'll
give you $200 for all of them."
After appearing in Sam Raimi's original
trilogy, fans of Spider-Man were thrilled
to see Simmons reprise his role in
a mid-credits scene for "Spider-Man:
Far From Home." Simmons then played a small
role as Peter Parker's loudest critic in the
follow-up, "No Way Home," and makes a
comeback via voiceover in "Across the
Spider-Verse," protesting the actions of
Spider-People throughout the multiverse.
The character even briefly
appears in the flesh — or rather,
brick — during one sequence that takes
place in the world of LEGO Spider-Man,
which is the only time in the film Peter
Parker's work at The Daily Bugle is referenced.
Gwen Stacy's backstory is only briefly
alluded to in "Into the Spider-Verse,"
as her character introduction explains
how her best friend, Peter Parker,
became The Lizard and was subsequently
defeated by Gwen in battle. However,
the opening of "Across the Spider-Verse" delves
deeper into the characters and what led to this
moment, which all originates in Gwen Stacy's
introduction as Spider-Gwen in Marvel Comics.
After getting bitten by a radioactive spider,
Gwen begins living a double life as Spider-Woman,
using her powers of super-strength to intimidate
Peter Parker's bullies on the side. However,
fed up with being picked on, Parker downs The
Lizard's serum, turning himself into a monster
that attacks their school prom as an act of
revenge against his bullies. Gwen unknowingly
kills Peter in the subsequent fight, and runs away
when her father, Captain Stacy, shows up at the
scene of the crime to find Spider-Woman
standing over a murdered Peter Parker.
Although this is established in "Into the
Spider-Verse" as Gwen's reasoning for remaining
distant from others, its explanation in "Across
the Spider-Verse" follows the arc from her debut
comic. Some of the sequences in this extended
opening even mirror panels from the comic, such
as one moment when Peter injects himself with Dr.
Connors' serum. Peter's final words to Spider-Gwen
during this scene are also directly taken from
the comic, revealing he knew her secret identity.
The world of the MCU has been focused
on the concept of the multiverse lately,
from the bureaucracy policing the flow of
time in "Loki," to the introduction of the
next Avengers-level threat in the multiversal
conqueror Kang. However, "Into the Spider-Verse"
was the first Marvel film to really delve
into the comic book origins of the multiverse.
The multiverse also played a major role
in another Spider-Man film, "Spider-Man:
No Way Home," in which Tom Holland's Peter
Parker becomes the target of super-villains
from the Sonyverse after convincing Doctor
Strange to toy with the memories of everyone
on Earth. These events seem to be obliquely
referenced in "Across the Spider-Verse" by
Miguel O'Hara during an early scene in the film
as he describes the instability of the multiverse.
"Don't even get me started on Doctor Strange
and the little nerd from Earth-199999."
Ganke Lee, in Marvel Comics, is Miles Morales'
best friend as well as one of the few people
who knows his secret identity. However,
the character's appearance in "Into the
Spider-Verse" was as a minor non-speaking
role, seen most notably when he walks
in on Miles and the other Spider-People
hiding in their shared dorm room. However,
Ganke makes a slightly more prominent
appearance in "Across the Spider-Verse"
when Miles stops in his dorm after capturing
The Spot and asks Ganke to call the cops.
During the brief moment between Miles and Ganke,
Ganke expresses disinterest in being Miles' "guy
in the chair," which results in him not
doing anything when The Spot eventually
escapes captivity. For fans of the Tom Holland
Spider-Man movies, the phrase "guy in the chair"
will sound a little familiar, as it's said
many times by Peter Parker's friend Ned Leeds.
"Hey, can I be your guy in the chair?"
"What?"
"You know how there's a guy with a headset
telling the other guy where to go?"
This Easter egg also references some
connective tissue between Ganke Lee
and the MCU's Ned Leeds— the latter looks
visually much closer to Ganke Lee in the
comics than he does to the Ned Leeds
that eventually becomes the Hobgoblin.
Phil Lord and Christopher Miller have a long
history of producing and creating animated films,
including "Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs"
and "The Mitchells vs. the Machines." The two
also co-produced "Into the Spider-Verse,"
and returned to help pen the scripts for
both "Across the Spider-Verse" and
2024's "Beyond the Spider-Verse."
Given their greater creative input on the
second and third films of the trilogy,
Lord and Miller saw an opportunity to pay tribute
to one of their biggest successes in animation.
That success is "The LEGO Movie," which
the creative duo co-wrote and co-directed,
was released in 2014 to glowing reviews
for its stop-motion-style animation and
storytelling. The two also co-wrote
and produced the film's 2019 sequel,
"The LEGO Movie 2: The Second Part," as well
as producing "The LEGO Batman Movie," "The
LEGO Ninjago Movie," and spin-off
Cartoon Network series "Unikitty!".
In "Across the Spider-Verse," Lord and Miller
go back to their LEGO roots for a moment in
the film when The Spot, while jumping
between multiverses, ends up creating
havoc in the animated world of LEGO Spider-Man.
Slipping away from his job at The Daily Bugle,
LEGO Spider-Man himself contacts Miguel
O'Hara and the Spider-Society to alert
them to the danger of The Spot, setting off
many of the events of the film. Though it's
a moment mostly played for laughs, it's a fun
Easter egg for Lord and Miller's past work.
Lord and Miller's work isn't the only thing
referenced during The Spot's multiverse-jumping
in "Across the Spider-Verse." When The Spot
crashes into the LEGO Spider-Man world,
he also mistakenly ends up in the live-action
Sony-Verse, where he has a brief interaction
with Mrs. Chen, played by Peggy Lu, the
owner of a convenience store that Tom
Hardy's Eddie Brock frequents in "Venom" and
its sequel, "Venom: Let There Be Carnage."
Hilariously, Mrs. Chen is unfazed by the
presence of The Spot, which may have something
to do with the fact that she is briefly a
symbiote host in "Let There Be Carnage."
While hanging out at night with
his Uncle Aaron, Miles is, like
many Spider-People across the multiverse,
bitten by a radioactive spider. However,
what makes Miles an anomaly is that his
spider came to his homeworld of Earth-1610
from a different universe, Earth-42, with
Miles' acquisition of powers resulting in
the death of his universe's Peter Parker
and the instability of the multiverse.
Though this fact plays an important role in why
Miguel O'Hara targets Miles, as well as why Miles
himself ends up on Earth-42 at the end of the
film, the number on that spider is no coincidence.
Miles Morales co-creator Brian Michael
Bendis numbered the radioactive spider
as a nod to the legendary baseball
player Jackie Robinson, who wore the
number 42. The number pops up in a number
of places throughout "Into the Spider-Verse"
and Miles can be seen wearing a jersey with
the number 42 in "Across the Spider-Verse."
The number 42 also holds additional meaning
for sci-fi fans. In "The Hitchhiker's Guide
to the Galaxy," 42 is established as
the answer to, as the book states,
"the ultimate question of life,
the universe, and everything."
"Yes, yes, I've thought it over
quite thoroughly. It is. It's 42."
While Miguel thinks that Miles' status as
a universe-ending anomaly is a problem,
maybe it means that he's the answer instead.
In the history of "Spider-Man" as a
film franchise, there is probably no
scene as iconic as the big romantic moment
in Sam Raimi's 2002 film. You know the one:
After rescuing Kirsten Dunst's Mary
Jane Watson from a group of muggers
in the rain, an upside-down Tobey Maguire
passionately kisses his high school crush.
While few romantic pairings have been able to hold
a candle to Maguire and Dunst in "Spider-Man,"
Miles and Gwen's flirtations in "Across
the Spider-Verse" come pretty close.
Before Gwen disappears into a portal to
chase down The Spot, she turns around,
unknowingly face-to-face with an upside-down,
invisible Miles. Though they don't end up locking
lips, it's still a nice homage to one of the
most iconic scenes in "Spider-Man" history,
and sets up their romantic tension
to continue in the next film.
Aunt May isn't as present in "Across
the Spider-Verse" as she was in "Into
the Spider-Verse," with Miles establishing
early in the film that she moved to Florida.
Though this seems like a random fact, it
actually has some basis in Aunt May's comic
book origins. The Aunt May that appears in the
Miles Morales comics has family that lives in
Florida, making her move there in "Across the
Spider-Verse" potentially a homecoming for her.
Of course, Florida is also a popular
state for elderly citizens to retire in,
so maybe we're reading too much into Aunt
May's choice of new destination. Still,
in the tangled web of the "Spider-Verse" films,
no details go unnoticed, so it's possible that
Aunt May has her own adventure ahead of
her when she arrives in the sunshine state.
"Into the Spider-Verse" was heralded as an
outstanding tribute to the history of Marvel
Comics. Not only do the different characters of
the films embody differing comic book aesthetics,
but the film's narrative also cleverly
utilizes comic book tropes to enhance
the storytelling. One example of
this is through its use of comic
book flourishes to make the film feel
like a comic book page brought to life.
In "Across the Spider-Verse,"
there are many moments that
utilize "Editor's Notes" which briefly
flash on-screen to, as they do in comics,
provide context for the audience on
characters, cultural differences,
and unexplained lore. However, one Editor's
Note in "Across the Spider-Verse" makes a
callback to a beloved character from
"Into the Spider-Verse": Spider-Ham.
During the confrontation between the Renaissance
Vulture and Gwen Stacy, Miguel O'Hara,
and Jessica Drew, O'Hara comments on Vulture's use
of "Hammerspace." According to an Editor's Note,
"Hammerspace" refers to a cartoon character's
ability to pull objects, such as a large hammer,
out of their pockets seemingly from thin
air. Obviously, those who have seen "Into
the Spider-Verse" recognize this as an ability
possessed by Spider-Ham, who actually does pull
a comically-large hammer out of his pocket
during one of the film's climactic scenes.
In 2018, two major Spider-events happened:
"Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse" hit theaters,
and Insomniac Games released "Spider-Man" for the
PlayStation 4. Since then, Insomniac has developed
several expansions and sequels, including
2020's "Spider-Man: Miles Morales" which
re-tells the origin story of the "Spider-Verse"
protagonist and his partnership with Peter Parker.
Naturally, the Insomniac Games iterations
of "Spider-Man" make multiple appearances
in "Across the Spider-Verse." At
first, Miles' roommate Ganke Lee
can be seen playing "Spider-Man" on his TV
instead of writing an essay during several
early scenes in the film. However, the more
prominent cameo comes way later in the film,
when Miles is being taken to meet Spider-Man
2099 in the Spider-Society's headquarters.
At one point, the Insomniac Spider-Man,
as well as Insomniac's Miles Morales,
appear among the residents of Nueva York, in
a full CGI render, just like in the games.
The climax of "Across the Spider-Verse" comes when
Miles Morales is taken to Nueva York on Earth-928,
where Miguel O'Hara has gathered
the Spider-Society. The sequence
where Miles Morales is introduced to this
society is filled with more cameos than one
audience member would be able to spot in one
sitting. Predictably, most of these alternate
Spider-People originate from comic books or other
official Marvel-produced "Spider-Man" content.
Among some of the highlights are
Otto Octavius's Superior Spider-Man,
while Alfred Molina cameos as Doc Ock
through archival use of his voice from "No
Way Home." Other Spider-People that appear
include Spider-Doppelganger, Iron Spider,
Julia Carpenter's Spider-Woman, Peter Parkedcar,
Ultimate Tarantula, and Spider-Man 2211.
"Do I have web on my face? What's the deal?"
One of the most surprising cameos
in "Across the Spider-Verse" has
been a long time in the making. At one
point during Miles' exploration of the
Spider-Society's headquarters, he meets an
alternate version of his uncle Aaron Davis,
aka The Prowler. But this version of Aaron
Davis is played by a live-action Donald Glover,
who originally debuted the character in the MCU's
"Spider-Man: Homecoming" as a low-level criminal
whom Tom Holland's Peter Parker interrogates for
information about the Vulture. What might make
fans extra excited is that, this time,
Glover's actually wearing the costume.
Although a deleted post-credits scene in
"Homecoming" teased Glover's Aaron Davis' close
relationship with Miles Morales, the character
has yet to re-appear in the film franchise.
"Yeah, sorry, Miles, I'm not
gonna make it. I'm just stuck."
While the appearance of Glover
is enough to satisfy many fans,
it also serves as an Easter egg to the
origin of Miles Morales as a character.
According to comic book creator Brian Michael
Bendis, Miles' design was inspired by Glover,
who was the subject of an online fan campaign
to get him cast as Peter Parker in "The Amazing
Spider-Man." It won't be the last time you'll
see Glover in a Spider-Man related film,
either. The "Atlanta" creator is also set to
star in a future Sonyverse film as the minor
comic book character Hypno Hustler,
a frequent antagonist of Spider-Man.
The multiverse has played a major role in the
on-screen Marvel universe lately, largely thanks
to "Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse." In the
years following the end of the Infinity Saga in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe, Marvel characters
have begun exploring the multiverse, beginning
with the 2021 Disney+ series "Loki," which centers
on the god of mischief being recruited by the
mysterious Time Variance Authority, whose goal is
to maintain the sanctity of the Sacred Timeline.
In the first season finale of "Loki," Loki and his
female variant Sylvie bear witness to the Sacred
Timeline beginning to split as a result of their
confrontation with He Who Remains. That conception
of the multiverse features a blue tree-like
timestream branching off into different paths.
When Miguel O'Hara explains to Miles Morales
how the multiverse works in "Spider-Man:
Across the Spider-Verse," this familiar
imagery makes a return via a hologram.
At this point, Sony has gotten a little obsessed
with making reference to one popular "Spider-Man"
meme in their films. In the post-credits scene
of "Into the Spider-Verse," Miguel O'Hara is
introduced as Spider-Man 2099 as he travels to the
universe of the 1967 "Spider-Man" animated series,
recreating the meme image of two Spider-Men
pointing at each other in an alley.
The meme was again referenced on the
set of "No Way Home" when the three
actors also recreated the image during a
behind-the-scenes costume fitting. Now,
with the release of "Across the
Spider-Verse," the meme makes
its on-screen appearance yet another time,
albeit under slightly different circumstances.
After learning of the Spider-Society's intention
to let Miles' father be killed by The Spot,
Miles makes an escape from their facility as
O'Hara orders everyone to "stop Spider-Man."
"You?"
"Me?"
Even the casting choices in "Across the
Spider-Verse" contain Easter eggs. Among
the varied voice cast, there are also two members
of The Lonely Island, a sketch troupe that gained
notoriety on "Saturday Night Live" for creating
viral Digital Shorts like "Lazy Sunday" and
"The Shooting." Jorma Taccone, who previously
voiced several minor characters in "Into the
Spider-Verse," appears early on as a variant
of the Vulture inspired by Leonardo da Vinci.
Alongside Taccone, Andy Samberg also makes
an appearance in the film as Ben Reilly,
a.k.a. Scarlet-Spider, a moody variant who
serves as a high-up member of Miguel O'Hara's
Spider-Society. Reilly, a clone of Peter
Parker, made his comic book debut in 1975,
before he later adopted the Scarlet-Spider
persona in the '90s. During his first
appearance in the film, Samberg's Reilly is
seen in Nueva York contemplating his tragic
backstory before later joining O'Hara
in hunting down Morales on Earth-1610.
Samberg's appearance in particular may
be an Easter egg to his work on "Saturday
Night Live," as the comedian appeared on
several occasions dressed as Spider-Man
hanging upside down. One of those times was
during the monologue of Emma Stone in 2011,
where he unsuccessfully tried to
recreate the 2002 film's iconic
make-out scene with her in front of her
then-boyfriend and co-star Andrew Garfield.
"He's British! America's
suffering record unemployment
and we outsource Spider-Man to England?"
Despite his importance to Miles Morales' story
in "Into the Spider-Verse," Jake Johnson's
Peter B. Parker doesn't appear in "Across the
Spider-Verse" until towards the end, when he's
revealed to be another member of Miguel O'Hara's
Spider-Society. With him, Parker has taken along
his infant daughter, Mayday Parker, who has
adopted her father's ability to climb walls.
Mayday Parker is a fairly important
character in Marvel Comics history,
first appearing in a "What If...?" comic
from 1997 where Mary Jane Watson never
loses her baby with Peter Parker. Mayday
Parker is born and becomes Spider-Girl,
though in that comic Mayday's powers don't
develop until she's a teenager. She later
made her official Marvel Comics debut after
positive fan response to the "What If...?" comic.
Though the infant Mayday gets most of the
attention in "Across the Spider-Verse,"
other variants of Mayday also appear
throughout the Spider-Society sequence,
albeit ones that come from a different
universe than Peter B. Parker's.
After a cameo appearance in the post-credits scene
of "Into the Spider-Verse," the Spider-Man from
the 1967 ABC animated series makes a return
appearance in "Across the Spider-Verse."
This classic version of Peter Parker pops up to
attempt to stop Miles' escape from Nueva York.
Unfortunately, this version of Spider-Man doesn't
pose much of a threat and is almost
immediately dispatched by Miles.
This Peter Parker isn't even the only Spider-Man
who debuted on TV to make an appearance in "Across
the Spider-Verse." The Japanese Spider-Man
from the 1978 Japanese live-action series
also shows up as part of the Spider-Society,
accompanied by Josh Keaton's version of Peter
Parker from "The Spectacular Spider-Man."
And in a blink-and-you'll-miss-it moment,
the Spider-Man from "Spider-Man: Unlimited"
can be seen chasing Miles, web cape and all.
If you've been watching your Spider-Man movies,
then you probably noticed some familiar moves
from your favorite web-slinger. Or
web-slingers, as the case may be.
During one sequence where Miles, Gwen,
and Pavitr attempt to stop The Spot from
wreaking havoc in Mumbattan, Pavitr rescues a
bus full of citizens, including his girlfriend,
from falling off a bridge. You might notice
that the scene closely resembles the moment
in 2002's "Spider-Man," where Spider-Man rescues
a group of citizens, including Mary Jane Watson,
from the Roosevelt Island Tramway. It pops up
again in "Spider-Man: Homecoming," when Peter
saves his classmates, including his romantic
interest Liz, from the Washington Monument.
Another iconic Spider-Man move
that's referenced in "Across the
Spider-Verse" is Tom Holland's trying to
hold a split ferry together in "Spider-Man:
Homecoming," which is referenced by a
lone Spider-Man in Nueva York making
himself into a bridge that a crowd
of Spider-People try to run across.
The ending of "Across the Spider-Verse" features
some familiar faces for audience members who
loved "Into the Spider-Verse." Abandoned by
the Spider-Society, Gwen Stacy realizes that
Miles has ended up in the wrong universe, and
recruits a team of Spider-People to help rescue
him from the clutches of his alternate self. That
group includes "Into the Spider-Verse" characters
like Peni Parker, Peter Porker, and Spider-Man
Noir, as well as Peter B. Parker and Mayday.
However, Peni Parker's mech has
received some upgrades since the
last time audiences saw her
in "Into the Spider-Verse."
"I'm from New York in the year 3145. I
have a psychic link with a spider who
lives inside my father's robot.
And we're best friends forever."
In that film, her mech resembled an actual
spider, but this time around, it bears a closer
resemblance to Peni Parker's original mech design
from her "Edge of Spider-Verse" comic debut.
In turn, the comic book version of the mech is
its own Easter egg. The storyline of Peni Parker
drew lots of inspiration from "Neon Genesis
Evangelion", a Japanese anime centered on a
group of teenagers who pilot a weaponized
mech, just like Peni. According to artist
Jake Wyatt, he included several characters
from "Neon Genesis Evangelion" as Peni's
classmates in the "Edge of Spider-Verse"
comic as a tribute to their inspiration.
The twist ending of "Across the Spider-Verse"
finds Miles mistakenly ending up in the wrong
universe after using Miguel O'Hara's
technology to send himself home. Since
the spider that bit him was from
Earth-42 rather than Earth-1610,
Miles ends up in a version of his world
where there is no Spider-Man. Even worse,
the Miles of this world has been raised
by his uncle Aaron to become the Prowler.
What truly changes things for Miles is when
Aaron takes him to the roof of their building,
and Miles sees a graffiti tribute
to his father, Jefferson Davis,
instead of the tribute to Aaron in his universe.
If you were shocked by this twist, you might have
been too distracted to notice a subtle nod to
the creators of Miles Morales in this tribute.
Spray-painted in faint green ink near Jefferson
Davis' graffiti memorial are the words "Bendis"
and "Pichelli," which refer to writer Brian
Michael Bendis and illustrator Sara Pichelli.
The two creators of Miles Morales are
probably used to being referenced in this way,
since they also appeared in Miles' phone
contacts in "Into the Spider-Verse."
Bendis and Pichelli are also referenced
in "Spider-Man: Homecoming" in the files
for Donald Glover's Aaron Davis, with one of
his criminal aliases being "Brian Pichelli."